all right so you're always in one of
these little frameworks and there's just
no getting them out of it so and that's
because you know at any given moment
this is like it's like field theory
there used to be psychological theories
that talked about the field of human
experience something like that and this
is kind of what that is this is a field
and basically what happens is you parse
out a little part of the world say
and so amount you can handle so let's
say it has some duration you're not
aiming at something 50 years in the
future it's because how the hell are you
going to do that you there's too many
variables you know so you're aiming at
some handleable amount of time and you
posit a goal in there and you plot your
route and then that tells you what's up
and tells you what's down because up
moves you towards the goal and down
moves you away from the goal and that
sets up your motivation framework so
that you have some worth detaining you
know that's a really interesting thing
to know - it's like why have a goal well
it's easy no goal no positive emotions
because you experience positive emotion
by noticing that you're moving towards a
goal and so you don't have a goal well
you can't have any positive emotion so
you better have a goal and so you might
say well what should the goal be well we
could start by saying well any goal is
better than none and then we might say
well it should be a goal that other
people will let you pursue because
otherwise it's going to be kind of
difficult and maybe they'll be even
happy to help you pursue it that would
even be better and maybe it's a goal
that would enable you to learn how to
pursue other goals while you pursue that
goal boy that would really be good and
so you can see that your goal is
parameterised but that doesn't mean that
any old goal works it means there's some
goals that work nicely and some not so
nicely there are playable games and non
playable games that's a good way of
thinking about it and you want to have a
playable game and there's a lot of them
lawyer plumber
you know actor whatever they're your
playable games and and it's not obvious
which one's better but it's certainly
obvious which ones are sustainable in
which ones are worth so there's a set of
playable games and you need to extract
from that set of playable games
game it suits you and that would be
partly due to your temperament you know
because extroverted people want to play
an extroverted game and highly neurotic
people want to play a safe game and
agreeable people want to play a generous
game and disagreeable people want to
play a game that's highly competitive so
they can win and you know fine but
they're all within the realm of playable
games and that means they're socially
acceptable as well and so that means it
isn't just arbitrary
it isn't just relative what you decide
to do it's heavily parameterised there's
only there's a set of playable games and
it's large the set is large but it there
are commonalities within it and that's
why there are commonalities
that's why morality has a common basis
fundamentally and so that's partly what
we're trying to investigate is like
what's up what does that mean what does
it mean is there such a thing now
one thing to remember is that if you
don't erect a hierarchical structure
with a sum of the a map you got no
positive motivation because you
experience positive motivation in
relationship to a goal not from
attaining the goal that's satisfaction
besides it's fleeting you know perfectly
well you graduate from university poof
next day you have a problem which is
what do you do next and that's a that's
a tough problem it's not like you've
solved your problems by winning that
game you just introduce the problem of
having to introduce another game so it's
unreliable as a source of positive
emotion but what's reliable is you set a
goal and you try to attain it and then
that gives your life that literally
provides your life with meaning that's
what meaning is now it's more than that
but that's that's what it is
and so then you might ask yourself well
what's a really good goal well that's
what we're trying to figure out what's a
really good goal